oh que le ce gros sourire que ses pairs
le monsieur thual son croc apparel il y
un an que léo ferré n'avait pas paru sur
nos écrans la dernière fois d'ailleurs
c'était pour panorama qu'il était il
nous reçoit
très gentiment une nouvelle fois
pourquoi parce que tout d'abord c'est la
rentrée de léo ferré bientôt à bobino et
ce jour-là à gourdon la maison ferrer
était en émoi
pépé faisait des siennes madeleine
venait de terminer son livre mémoires
d'un magnétophone
léo lui était en colère sa maison de
disques dit-il lui supprime une chance
voici les deux versions de la faire
celle de sa firme tout d'abord la
chansons de ferré dit elle porte
préjudice
un imprésario connu ne pouvons l'éditer
sous peine d'être poursuivi pour
l'instant nous essayons d'arranger les
choses
version de léo ferré la voici
beaucoup moins nuancé moi ça me fait
rire ses histoires cette chanson
s'appelle à une chanteuse morte et une
chanson que j'ai écrite pour edith piaf
tout le monde connaît ce qu'elle a
beaucoup de talent j'écris une chanson
pour elle c'est une chanson tendre mais
bourru à des termes un peu plus certains
journalistes critiques appellent
brossier vous sa 105e que tout le monde
emploie je pense qu'on maintiendra pas
rigueur
la chose est simple je l'enregistré
c'est un disque de 13 chansons de mois
d'avril et se disent qu'ils ne sortent
pas pourquoi ne sont ils pas parce que
je j'imagine la scène
le directeur de la compagnie
phonographique française et à laquelle
j'appartiens par contrat jusqu'en 1970 a
dû recevoir un coup en la saône et il
est monté il allait chez lui et devant
monsieur le manager en question qui a dû
lui dire en ce moment j'imagine huit
mois est affairé de créer une chanson
qui me gêne
veuillez ne pas la publier et là d'une
faire ça n'est qu'un chien vous pouvez
euros mois pour enfermer la donne il
faut se lever de bonne heure sans que je
sois mort qu'on répond je parle peu il
le chante et voilà c'est la chantera
domino oui quoi qu'il arrive
ohlala espérons que tout cela
s'arrangera quand même je m'en fous
merci